♪ ♪
>> Tucker: HAVE YOU BEEN TO
AMERICA LATELY?
A LOT OF AMERICANS REALLY
HAVEN’T.
FOR MONTHS, MOST OF US HAVE
STAYED CLOSE TO HOME.
THE NEXT TIME YOU GO ON A PLANE
AND VISIT A COUPLE OF AMERICAN
CITIES, AN AWFUL LOT HAS CHANGED
IN A SHORT TIME.
CHURCHES ARE LOCKED ON SUNDAY
MORNING.
THAT’S WEIRD.
THE PARKS ARE FULL OF THE
HOMELESS.
WHEN YOU DO SEE PEOPLE, THEY
TEND TO BE WEARING MASKS AND
THEY WON’T GET CLOSE TO YOU.
IT’S A VERY STRANGE EXPERIENCE.
THE COUNTRY HAS CHANGED A LOT.
THE CULTURE HAS CHANGED A LOT,
AND REALLY NOT FOR THE BETTER.
SO THE QUESTION IS, HOW LONG
WILL THIS LAST?
HOW LONG WILL WE HAVE TO ENDURE
THIS?
WHEN WILL WE GET OUR COUNTRY
BACK?
WHEN CAN WE LIVE LIKE WE USED TO
LIVE?
THETHAT QUESTION IS RARELY ASKED
AND ASKING IS DISCOURAGED.
AT FIRST, AUTHORITIES TOLD US
THAT WE COULD RESUME OUR LIVES
AFTER THE CURB WAS FLATTENED.
THE CURVE STAYED FLAT.
SO, WE HAVE A NEW BENCHMARK FOR
WHEN WE CAN GET BACK.
WHEN WE GET A VACCINE EVERYTHING
WILL BE FINE ONCE WE CAN
VACCINATE AGAINST COVID-19.
THEY ARE STILL TELLING US THAT.
THE STATE OF VIRGINIA SAYS THAT
WHEN THE VACCINE FINALLY DOES
ARRIVE, IT WILL BE MANDATORY.
THEY DON’T REQUIRE A VACCINE FOR
HIV.
MENINGITIS EITHER.
NOW THEY HAVE CHANGED THAT.
NOT TRUE ANYMORE.
ACCORDING TO A NEW ANNOUNCEMENT
FROM THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION, IT WILL NOT BE THE
END OF ALL OF THIS.
IT WILL NEVER END.
YOU WILL STILL BE UNDER ARREST.
THE WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION
SAYS THAT REORDERING SOCIETY IS
THE GOAL.
"WE WILL NOT, WE CANNOT GO BACK
TO THE WAY THINGS WERE."
THAT’S A DIRECT QUOTE FROM THE
LEADER OF THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION, WHO BY THE WAY IT
IS NOT REALLY A DOCTOR.
BECAUSE COVID-19 IS NOT A PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS REALLY OR EVEN A
VIRUS.
"COVID-19 IS IN FACT, THIS MAY
SURPRISE YOU, COVID-19 IS REALLY
ABOUT GLOBAL WARMING.
AS HE PUTS IT, "THE COVID-19
PANDEMIC HAS GIVEN NEW IMPETUS
TO THE NEEDS TO ACCELERATE
EFFORTS TO RESPOND TO CLIMATE
CHANGE."
BUT YOU DIDN’T SEE THAT COMING.
EARLIER THIS MONTH, GATES POSTED
AN ESSAY TO HIS PERSONAL WEBSITE
ARGUING THE LESSON OF THE CORONA
PANDEMIC IS THAT THE REST OF US
WILL HAVE TO SACRIFICE EVEN MORE
TO SAVE THE EARTH FROM WARMING.
NOW, FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT
BILLIONAIRE GLOBAL INFLUENCERS,
THIS IS ALL PRETTY CONFUSING.
WHAT DOES THE CORONAVIRUS HAVE
TO DO WITH CLIMATE CHANGE?
WELL, FOR ONE THING, CHINA
CAUGHT BOTH OF THEM.
THAT IS DEFINITELY NOT THE POINT
THEY ARE MAKING.
BOTH OF THEM VOWED BEFORE CHINA
THEY WOULD NEVER CRITICIZE THE
CHINESE GOVERNMENT.
BUT YOU CAN BE ASSURED THAT’S
NOT THE CONNECTION THEY ARE
DRAWING.
NO.
FOR DR. TED ROSE AND BILL GATES,
PANDEMIC AND CLIMATE CHANGE
SHARE A VERY DIFFERENT
CONNECTION.
BOTH ARE USEFUL PRETEXTS FOR
MASS SOCIAL CONTROL.
BOTH ARE ESSENTIALLY UNSOLVABLE
CRISES THEY CAN HARNESS TO
BYPASS DEMOCRACY AND FORCED
POWERLESS POPULATIONS TO OBEY
THEIR COMMAND.
NOW IT MAKES SENSE.
EVER WONDERED WHY OUR LEADERS
CONSIDER THE CORONAVIRUS A MAJOR
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS BUT NOT
SUICIDES AND DRUG OVERDOSES?
THIS IS WHY.
WHEN A 26-YEAR-OLD MOTHER IN
NEW HAMPSHIRE DIES, THEY DON’T
GET MORE POWERFUL.
HER DEATH IS USEFUL TO DOMINIC
USEFULUSELESS TO THEM.
IN JUST A FEW WEEKS, DOUBLY
VIRUS SPREAD FROM CENTRAL CHINA
THROUGH EUROPE TO EVERY MAJOR
CITY IN THE WEST.
AS THAT HAPPENED, THE WORLD
HEALTH ORGANIZATION DID NOTHING
TO STOP IT, AND IN FACT SPREAD
MISINFORMATION AS IT WAS
HAPPENING.
THOSE ARE THE FACTS.
SO WHAT WOULD A RATIONAL PERSON
CONCLUDE FROM THOSE FACTS?
GLOBALIZATION HAS UPSIDES, OF
COURSE.
IT ALSO HAS RISKS.
PANDEMICS SPREAD VERY, VERY
FAST.
THEN, AS IT HAPPENED, OUR MOST
IMPORTANT INTERNATIONAL PUBLIC
HEALTH ORGANIZATION FAILED ON
PURPOSE.
IT IS CORRUPT.
THAT’S A HUGE PROBLEM.
BUT NO ONE IS LEARNING THAT.
ONE WAS THE LAST TIME YOU HEARD
BILL GATES SAY THOSE THINGS?
NEVER.
THEY NEVER WILL.
THEY DON’T BENEFIT FROM
ACKNOWLEDGING THE TRUTH.
THIS IS TRUE ABOUT ALL CRISIS.
THEY ONLY TAKE THE LESSONS THAT
EMPOWER THEM.
HOW ABOUT GLOBAL WARMING?
HOW MANY RATIONAL PERSONS AFFECT
GLOBAL WARMING?
THAT’S THE CLAIM THEY MAKE.
MAYBE THEY ARE RIGHT.
THEN YOU WANT TO TAKE A VERY
CLOSE LOOK AT THE FORCES BEHIND
THOSE CARBON EMISSIONS.
YOU WOULD ASK HARD QUESTIONS
ABOUT THE GLOBAL ECONOMY.
YOU WONDER, WHO IS PROFITING
FROM THIS SYSTEM THAT IS
DESTROYING THE EARTH?
HOW EXACTLY DO THE RICHEST, MOST
POWERFUL PEOPLE IN THE EARTH
CONTRIBUTE TO CARBON EMISSIONS?
THAT WOULD BE THE FIRST QUESTION
YOU WOULD ASK.
THAT’S A LOGICAL WAY TO THINK
ABOUT CLIMATE CHANGE.
AND IF YOU BEGAN TO THINK THAT
WAY, YOU MIGHT WIND UP
CONCLUDING THAT PEOPLE LIKE I
DON’T KNOW, MICHAEL BLOOMBERG
WERE IN FACT CLIMATE CRIMINALS.
THEIR PRIVATE JETS PRODUCE MORE
CARBON THAN AFRICAN VILLAGES,
NOT TO MENTION YOUR OWN
NEIGHBORHOOD.
A LOT MORE.
APPARENTLY NO ONE EVER
CRITICIZES MICHAEL BLOOMBERG.
HE’S CONSIDERED A LEADER IN THE
FIGHT AGAINST CLIMATE CHANGE.
ON THE BASIS OF THE NUMBERS,
THAT IS LUDICROUS.
BUT IF YOU SAY IT WITH A
STRAIGHT FACE AND COMMAND, YOU
BELIEVE IT.
ALL OF US TEND TO PLACE
OURSELVES IN THE BAROQUE CENTER
OF OUR OWN NARRATIVES.
THAT’S PARTICULAR PARTICULARLY T
PEOPLE.
BUT IN THIS CASE, THEY ARE
EVADING RESPONSIBILITY.
THEY ARE PROFITING DIRECTLY FROM
A SYSTEM THEY CLAIM IS
RESPONSIBLE.
IT’S YOUR FAULT.
YOU ARE THE ONE WHO IS DOING IT.
YOU ARE THE ONE.
YOU HAVE A PICKUP TRUCK.
YOU FORGOT TO WEAR YOUR LITTLE
MASK.
YOU ARE GOING TO --
WE WILL BE AT THE YELLOWSTONE
CLUB HAVING A DRINK.
IT’S A SCAM.
IT’S AN OBVIOUS SCAM.
HERE’S ANOTHER DATA POINT FOR
YOU.
THAT YOU WON’T SEE ON
TELEVISION.
JULY 31ST, THE CDC, CENTER FOR
DISEASE CONTROL, OUR PRIMARY
PUBLIC HEALTH ORGANIZATION
FUNDED BY THE GOVERNMENT
RELEASED GUIDELINES ABOUT
PATIENTS INFECTED WITH THE
CORONAVIRUS.
HOW DO YOU TRACK THE SPREAD OF
THE DISEASE?
IN A FOOTNOTE, THE CDC
ACKNOWLEDGED THAT RESEARCHERS
LACKED EVIDENCE THAT "MASKS
OFFER ANY PROTECTION AGAINST
CORONAVIRUS."
ANY AT ALL.
HEALTH OFFICIALS WORKED TO TRACK
THE SPREAD OF THE VIRUS AND CDC
SUGGESTED THAT THEY IGNORED
WHETHER OR NOT PEOPLE WERE
WEARING MASKS.
IN OTHER WORDS, IT MIGHT BE
COMPLETELY IRRELEVANT TO
PREVENTING THE SPREAD OF THE
VIRUS.
SO THERE IS STILL NO PROOF THAT
MASKS PROTECT US AGAINST
COVID-19?
THE CDC PUT THAT IN A RELEASE TO
THE STATE.
IT SEEMS LIKE A BLOCKBUSTER
STORY.
WHY ISN’T THAT ON PAGE ONE OF
"THE NEW YORK TIMES"?
WHY IS THE ENTIRE MEDIA, THE
ENTIRE LEADERSHIP CLASS OF THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA
IGNORING THIS?
MASKS ARE OBLIGATORY ANYWHERE.
HE JUST ANNOUNCED THAT IF HE IS
ELECTED, YOU WILL BE REQUIRED TO
WEAR A MASK WHEN YOU ARE ALONE
OUTSIDE.
WHAT IS GOING ON?
YOU KNOW WHAT IS GOING ON.
FEAR WORKS.
THE MORE AFRAID YOU ARE, THE
MORE YOU WILL ACCEPT.
AGAIN, IT’S HUMAN NATURE.
THE MORE CUT OFF YOU ARE FROM
YOUR FAMILY AND YOUR FRIENDS,
THE MORE POWER THEY HAVE TO
CONTROL YOU.
THIS IS AN ELECTION YEAR.
DEMOCRATS WANT TO WIN IN
NOVEMBER.
THE VIRUS IS THEIR MAIN SHOT TO
WIN.
THEY ARE USING FEAR OF THE
CORONAVIRUS TO ACHIEVE THAT.
FOR EXAMPLE, POLLING PLACES,
THEY WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE MORE OF
THEM.
WHY?
TO FORCE THE VOTE BY MAIL.
BECAUSE VOTE BY MAIL IS MORE
EASY TO MANIPULATE.
THE LATEST RELIEF BILL WOULD
BRING BALLOT HARVESTING TO EVERY
STATE.
IT’S NOT SCIENCE.
IT’S POLITICS.
HERE IS THE KEY THING TO
REMEMBER.
ALL OF US ARE ASSUMING.
THIS WILL END IF JOE BIDEN WINS.
ON INAUGURATION DAY, NO MORE
LOCKDOWNS.
DON’T BET ON IT.
THE WUHAN PANDEMIC HAS MADE OUR
LEADERSHIP CLASS MORE POWERFUL
THAN THEY HAVE EVER BEEN.
WHY WOULD THEY RELINQUISH THAT?
THE ONLY POLITICIAN IN AMERICA